when i went to ski with chris chris uh i
had a bit of an accident and then
couldn't ski
very well i was doing all right i didn't
ski in a few years and then i just fell
over and my leg was [ __ ] and i just
couldn't sleep the rest of the day
oh [ __ ] yeah it was awful that's
dangerous it's really dangerous i just
kept falling over i was snowboarding
down and i was waiting at the bottom
for chris and i just see this like mini
avalanche forming
a snowball literally like i'm just
watching him and i look at my phone for
one second i look up and i just see
the clouds coming clouds of snow
falling and then i'm like oh [ __ ]
you're right chris but then when you're
at the bottom you're like you can't do
anything yeah
he said to stand there come on chris
good luck chris your friend would have
climbed up for me
oh [ __ ] great [ __ ] that was so far up
i couldn't i couldn't go
how much further did you go down
compared to him didn't wait for him no
so what it was
like a true friend it was kind of like a
long extended one and so i always just
try and stay in view so when it's in
when i get to the bottom of it i'll just
wait for the bottom of the
until the next slope starts and i just
wait at the bottom because chris is
going really slow
i try and stay in view sorry is that
chris binoculars out there
and then just talk was coming and then
he just fell down i was savouring the
moment i just feel bad saving the moment
take that time savoring the
was injury knee okay afterwards because
he was pretty beaten up on the day i
think yeah i think i didn't stretch very
well before
and then when i fell over like twisted
my leg and then every time i put
pressure on it i was
[ __ ] yeah i know it's because take
precautions when skiing yeah
be careful don't do a chris don't do a
chris don't do chris you end up like
that
everything else was successful
everything the acid bath that was a good
trick
that's a fun trip what's next
next yeah i want to extreme sports
videos
are you going to climb out feed you then
i want to yeah that's what we want
stream
did you see they opened it but at the
top what yeah they opened it to the what
is it the
the halfway college right oh [ __ ] yeah
you in the ticket
it gets very crowded at the top it's not
like it's not like a mountain
when you get the top it's just like
waiting for a thing part ride takes the
magic out i can assure you and uh
and they were worried that people would
spread covered up there right as a
result but
it's god imagine getting coconut water
if you've got a cave at the top about
fiji well done
yeah it's a shame though because there's
no point climbing it this year then yeah
not really it's that long
maybe do something like that but yeah
unfortunately i have to be next to you
yeah
unfortunately that would have been fun
climb up krakatoa something
crackers
is like the biggest volcano in indonesia
yeah
oh i've watched that yeah trash taste
versus crackers oh my god no
trash this is k2 didn't erupt and
destroy most of southeast asia
yeah i mean that way it was i think it's
like why do you sound so happy about
that when you say this is 200 000 years
ago
yeah yeah i think it's like the site of
the biggest volcanic eruption
in like historic can't do that lovely
that's a runner-up yeah for you guys
is